All right. Well hello everyone.
Thank you so much for joining today.
My name is Helen Riley and I work in
finance and I support Lorraine on global
marketing as well as uh,
Patrick and David [inaudible].
And I am,
but one of the best things about my job
is that I head up developments together
with Lisa Give Elba,
uh, for women at Google.
And one of the new things that we
decided to launch this year was a speaker
series. And so I reached
out to my colleagues and the
People Dev Organization. Um,
and actually one of the first names that
came up was, um, Sally Helgeson. Um,
and so I'm delighted to have
Sally come talk to us today.
So Sally is a, an internationally
acclaimed author and speaker.
She's done a number of
corporate leadership events
with a number of corporations,
a well known IBM, Microsoft,J
and J. HP among others. Um,
and she's also the author of six books.
Um, and her latest book is called the,
the feminine, the female female vision.
Yeah, he was mixed up feminine female,
the female vision. So she's here
today to talk to us about some of the,
some of the lessons from,
from that book.
I'm talking about what it is to
articulate a clear vision, you know,
how do we build a allegiances within
an organization, how do we, you know,
project presence and, and a
half, um, executive presence.
So a number of things she's
going to be talking about. Um,
so I'm delighted to hand over to Sally.
Thank you so much for joining us.
Thank you.
Thank you so much.
It is a pleasure to be here and I want
to thank Helen and women at Google.
Uh, it's my first visit to the
campus and I love being here.
I love seeing all the dogs around.
It just puts you in a great mood
and all the bikes. Um, so it's, uh,
it's a real pleasure and what I want to
do today is to share some of what I have
learned over 25 years of researching
and working with women leaders in
organizations all around the world.
And I want to focus that on things that
you as women can do to develop your own
leadership style. And for the men in the
audience, both in the room and out there,
uh,
and uh,
different locations to also give you
some insights in ways that you can,
uh,
drive some of the best talents
from the women that you manage.
Um, so I'm going to be drawing
a lot of information here.
I'm going to be focusing on some of the
things that I learned both in writing my
most recent book, the female
vision, women's real power at work.
Uh, and the, some of the things that
I've learned in the years since,
because I've worked with that material
to help women in hands on workshop and
coaching situations,
use the insights and the research in that
book to their own leadership style and
position themselves well
in their organizations.
So that's what I'll be doing.
I'm going to do this in pretty
much three parts briefly.
I want to give you a bit of background
so you can understand where this focus
comes from, the kinds of
experiences that drove it. A,
then I want to share with you what I
think of as two really red hot insights
from the book,
the female vision.
And then I want to have a real
discussion about how that,
those insights can be applied to you
in the management of your own careers.
So let me start by giving you a
bit of background. Uh, as I said,
I've been doing this for 25 years,
uh,
and my journey working with women leaders
and research and women leaders began,
uh,
when I did the research that became the
book published in 1990 called the female
advantage women's ways of
leadership, uh, books still,
it has been continuously in print and was,
I'm very proud to say the first book
that focused on what women had to
contribute to organizations rather than
how they needed to change and adapt that
had not been out there before.
Uh,
like many books that really
hit a nerve with people.
I've never spoken.
I once had an Elvis impersonator
in the next room in Las Vegas,
but there's nothing we can do.
We've just got the music. Okay.
I'll try to groove with it. Um, um, I, uh,
the book came from my very
personal experience. Uh,
I had made a career shift in the mid,
late eighties.
I had moved from being an independent
journalist and writer to working with
corporate executives and helping them
writing their speeches and working with
them to deliver their
speeches more effectively.
And in making that change,
I was concerned about how I was going
to be perceived in the organization.
I felt like a double outside.
There were very,
very few women at the level that I
was operating at. So I did two things.
I studied the men around me and I also
read a lot of books because there were
books that were being written at that
time for women coming into organizations
about what they needed
to do to be successful.
And I got a lot from what I was reading.
It was quite helpful to me,
but I noticed that every single thing
I read focused on how women needed to
change their leadership style in
order to adapt to the workplace.
There was nothing,
there was no acknowledgement that women
might have something to contribute or
that what they might have to contribute.
It could be valuable to organizations
in helping them change and,
and, and thrive in a rapidly
changing environment.
One thing I've learned is
women are, are really, uh,
avid consumers of books about
what is wrong with them.
But it seemed to be that there was room
to look at what women could contribute
and that that would be helpful. So I
decided to really on my own initiative,
uh, to start interviewing
and then doing diary studies.
So as shadowing,
uh,
some of America's best women leaders to
try to define what it was that they did
that w could be powerful for other
women to learn from and they could be
powerful for organizations to
understand what they had to contribute.
The women I studied were very
different, uh, ethnically,
geographically in terms of what sector
they were in. There was a big range,
but what I found was that there were five
characteristics that these women often
very different had in common.
First,
the women placed a very high value on the
quality of the relationships that they
built,
but also the relationships that women
generally in there or that people
generally in their organizations
were able to build with one another.
So there were very relationship focused.
The women had a bias for
direct communication rather
than communication up and
down a chain of command.
They wanted to talk directly to
whomever something concerned.
The women like to put themselves in
the center of things and lead from the
center rather than the top.
Some of them even put their offices in
the center of their organizations and
create what I called Webs of inclusion
to draw people in around the women.
Ha we're comfortable with as
opposed to tolerant of diversity.
They themselves have been outsiders
and had fresh eyes for understanding,
uh, the kinds of things, the
kind of value that outsiders,
an outsider perspective could provide.
And they also knew from
personal experience what
condescending behavior felt
like.
And finally,
the women were skilled at integrating
their personal and their professional
lives. And drawing on. A number of them
said to me, made a point of saying,
you know,
I'm the same person at work,
that I am at home as a mother,
as a sister, as a wife,
as a member of my community. And that
gives me a real source of strength.
And they were good at drawing information
from their private lives and using it
at work and vice versa.
Now what has been really extraordinary
in my experience is to watch over the
last that was put out there in 1990
and those characteristics are now have
become in the years since really
thought of and often defined as women's
leadership characteristics.
But what has been amazing is to watch
the way in which those characteristics
have become much more mainstream and
recognized as characteristics of excellent
leaders in general that I've
been able to witness that.
And it has been really extraordinary.
And it is because the environment,
the economic environment that we're part
of technology and of course demographic
change have all supported the,
the recognition of those leadership
characteristics as important as
organizations have had to connect more
directly with customers and clients.
They've gotten more
focused on relationships.
Tell you when the female advantage
came out and I talked about that value,
the woman placed on relationships,
I was told don't,
don't go there because talking about
relationships makes it sound very soft and
it's not good for women. Now every bank
wants to have a relationship with you.
There's a real emphasis on
the value of relationships.
Obviously comfort with diversity.
More and more important as we have
more diverse and globalized workforce,
the ability to put yourself in the
center of things rather than the top.
More adaptive as more work
gets done in teams and webs.
Uh, the ability to integrate
personal and professional. Again,
more important,
more adaptive as we move into a 24,
seven environment.
And obviously a bias for
direct communication is
more and more of a necessary
skill given the nature of
networked technologies.
So it has been extraordinary to watch
this sort of confluence between what I
saw.
Women often bringing two organizations
where these characteristics had not been
defined as leadership characteristics
and the way in which the environment was
demanding these qualities. In fact, um,
it was so interesting to me a
couple months ago, Tom Friedman,
the New York Times columnists,
did a series called what it
takes to work at Google, uh,
in which he interviewed Laszlo Bock
and talked about what leadership
characteristics Google was looking for.
And I wrote a blog about it
cause I blogged for strategy
and business magazine,
the extraordinary overlap between
what Bach was describing as desirable
characteristics for leaders,
especially skill,
relationship building,
the ability to work seamlessly in webs
and teams and assume different positions
within them,
putting yourself in the middle.
And I thought it is extraordinary that
what Bach is describing 25 years ago,
20 years ago were really considered
women's leadership strengths.
And I think that has,
uh,
been very much to the advantage
not only of many women,
but it has also freed many men to
explore other sides of themselves and
recognize that they could be strong
leaders while doing that. Um,
so I think it has been a very
good thing that said, um,
about 2006 or 2007 even I tend to be
a glass half full type person began to
think now there's something amiss here.
If women are bringing these skills often
to organizations and these skills are
becoming recognized more as mainstream
leadership skills and organizations are
often hiring women at 50% and women are
becoming a increasingly represented at
the top in terms of business
and professional schools.
Why aren't there more women at the very
top where they're making the kinds of
decisions that have the real strategic
influence on the direction of their
organizations and on
our society as a whole?
Why is there a leadership
barrier or gap still in place,
especially given this confluence between
what women bring and what organizations
increasingly need and what
caught my eye as I try,
as I pondered this and a lot of other
people who who are in this field generally
we're thinking about
that then and still are.
What struck me were two studies that
I came across, one done in Madrid,
one done in at NC add the
sort of the HBS of uh,
of France and Europe generally.
Um,
both of which were big global studies
and both of which showed the same thing.
What they showed is that when interviewing
senior leaders in organizations about
what,
where they saw women's strengths
and women's weaknesses,
the kinds of characteristics we've
been talking about, collaboration,
relationship building, direct
communication, negotiation, uh,
the senior leaders felt that the women
really demo that the women that in their
organizations demonstrated
them but demonstrated them,
but consistently what
those senior leaders sad,
the point where they felt women had
a weakness or needed to develop more
strength was around
the question of vision,
big picture thinking,
longterm focus.
So the executives in these two huge global
studies or critical of their women in
terms of their capacity for vision.
And this was an impediment to women's
perception of being ready for leadership.
And I,
what was fascinating also in the study,
because women often routinely tend to
under assess themselves and their skills
based on how they're perceived by others,
is the women didn't see this gap at all.
The women felt that they had a strong
vision that they have longterm.
Uh,
th th they were represented longterm
thinking and big picture focus very well.
So I thought something
isn't translating here.
Maybe it's time to explore what vision
really is in organizations and where
there may be a gap where women's vision
may not be translating in organizations
so that it can be understood
and recognized and valued
by senior leaders doing
that seemed to me an extremely
worthwhile project because in doing so,
I thought there's an opportunity to,
on one hand,
help women to better understand the nature
of their vision and articulate it in
a way that can be heard.
And at the same time,
there's an opportunity to
help organizations recognize
the power of vision that
women have the capacity to bring.
So this became my quest.
This became sort of in my view,
the next frontier that we
needed to research and get
some ideas and some answers
for in terms of what the,
the next area think about development
of leadership capacity for women.
So that's what I began focusing on and
I want to very briefly share to insights
from the really huge research
project that I undertook with a team,
uh,
to identify and articulate what
the female vision is and what its,
where its power could reside.
And then we'll open it up and start to
look at what does this mean for you next
Monday morning in terms of building a
leadership style that can lead you to make
a contribution that really
reflects your best talents,
your true talents,
and create a career for yourself.
That's very satisfying in
the course of doing that.
The two insights, so I want to
do this briefly. The first one,
and this I think is really a big deal.
What we learned not just from
doing interviews and case studies,
but also from working with
some neuroscientific labs
at Ucla and Columbia that
were doing research on what happens
when people's brains are operating.
What we learned is that,
and of course we're humans,
so there's always a spectrum here.
It's not all men are this way
and all women are that way,
but what we learned is that in general
women's attention tends to
operate in some distinctive ways.
What women notice,
which is a building block of vision.
Think about what is vision.
Vision is what you notice.
Then it's what you value about what you
notice and then it's the story you tell
yourself about why what
you're noticing is important.
So notice is really the
building block of vision,
this primary building block and what
we found is that women's women tend to
notice a lot of things at once and this
is verifiable in neuroscientific labs.
When they hook up people up to
functional Mris and watch the brain and
operation,
women are noticing all the time.
They're noticing different things at once.
They're attention is scanning
and operating kind of light,
a radar and they're processing
and parallel a lot of
information from different
sources.
Whereas men tend to have a much
more focused style of noticing,
looking at one thing at a time,
focusing in on it with their attention,
operating more like a
laser rather than a radar.
And this matters,
this matters when we think
about leadership because
in many organizations in
many organizations focused
notice is perceived of and
privileged as a leadership
style.
And those who have a more broad spectrum
notice as we called it in the book,
are thought of sometimes as being all
over the place by those who have very
focused notice.
I can give you an example,
a day to day example of how this operates
and what some of the consequences are.
Right here in the bay area, uh,
spent some time with a woman,
Susan Bernstein. She gotten her Mba,
she joined a hot shot consulting firm.
And uh, when she came in
she was told, you know,
your first big client case, your first
big meeting. Want you to go to that?
Don't say anything.
Just notice.
Just notice what is going on in that room.
So Susan went to the meeting and she
noticed and what she noticed was that the
two chief clients on this project
couldn't stand one another,
nor could their staffs that it
was there and their body language.
There was a real feeling
of tension in the room.
And when she came back to a meeting and
she was asked, what? What did you notice?
She said that she said,
what I noticed,
the big thing I noticed is that these
two guys seem to be at one another's
throats.
And what she was told was,
that's not what you
were supposed to notice.
You're not there as an HR consultant.
You are there as a business consultant.
What you were supposed to notice was
the presentation and the numbers.
How did you think they added up?
And she said,
I went away from that meeting
thinking, boy, did I blow it.
I will never do that again.
And she said,
I spent the next seven years in that
organization suppressing my capacity to
notice what was going on among people
so that I could better fit the mold.
She said in the result of that,
the result of that was that I lost my
passion for what I was doing because I
felt inauthentic.
I felt as if I was constantly using energy
to suppress what my best observations
were. Uh, and she said,
and Oh, by the way,
six months after I joined that team,
that project blew up and it blew up.
Not because the numbers were poor,
but because these two guys were at one
another's throats and ended up in a
lawsuit that in fact involved us.
He said,
so there was a real consequence
for me suppressing that,
but I still knew and I understood and
I was given to understand that that
information was not what my
company wanted me to here.
So there's an example of the,
the cost of suppressing the
power of what you notice. Um,
it seemed very,
very clear to me and one of the
things that I have come to believe
is that this capacity for Broadspectrum
notice is something that in 10 or 15
years we will really recognize
as a leadership attribute
in the same way that we
have come to recognize
skill at collaboration,
relationship building and
direct communication as a
strong leadership attribute.
Um,
I think that because organizations are
changing so rapidly and innovation is so
much apart of where
organizational value gets defined,
that that capacity broad spectrum
notice will become more important.
And the more prepared we are to recognize
what it is and articulate its value in
a way. And this what we'll be getting to
in the sort of how to part of this, uh,
that laser light noticers can understand
the more opportunity we'll have to
position ourselves for
really for leadership and for
being able to leverage the
power of that. I think that's
going to happen after I'd, um,
about a couple of months after
the female vision came out,
I read an interview with Jeff Immelt,
the chair and CEO of Ge and he was
asked what is the number one leadership
capability that Ge is going to be
hiring for and training for in the years
ahead.
And what he said was the capacity to
see around the corners because that's
what's needed in today's environment.
And I thought,
how are you going to see
around the corners unless
you're skilled at harnessing
both broad spectrum and
focus notice when they,
when they work together,
you've got an opportunity to get more
information than you would if it were
alone.
So I'm going to stop for a moment and um,
cause that's a certain amount of material.
I do have one other insight
from the book and then we'll,
we'll drill down more on to,
uh,
asking you to think about
how this might apply to you.
But are there any questions here on,
uh,
the question of notice or on the
leadership capabilities that we've been
discussing or the way in which,
uh,
those have become more
recognized as mainstream?
Has that been your experience?
Uh,
do you have anything that you can
share on that? Uh, it's actually, um,
rather enlightening for you to say that
that broad spectrum notice or the women
aren't considered to have much vision is
one of the things you want to point out.
Because actually I left my
last role because my manager,
a male manager said I didn't have any
strategy or vision. And I said, well,
you're ignoring the project.
I've been spending most of my time doing,
which is a strategic
vision for the next step.
And I came over here to Google in order
to work for a woman who I think thinks I
have strategy and vision. But I think, um,
my question then is if you feel
that you do a strategy and vision,
how do you express that to so many things?
You don't.
Someone who'd thinks you're dumb. So
this will get us a little more. We can,
we can do this move into what some of the,
um,
some of the practices that
have been talking about, uh,
that we'll be focusing on here.
So let me get into that in answer to
your question because I think that's sort
of the key question.
How do you,
if you think like the
women in the studies,
if you think you've got strong vision
and a strategic way of thinking,
how do you,
as it were,
translate that to somebody who may
have a very narrow noticing style and
therefore is judging you as someone who
doesn't because you're not articulating
it in ways that they're comfortable
with. How do you do that? Um,
and most of this I've really learned
since the book came out working with women
to develop their capacity to articulate
and translate what their vision is.
A couple of things that I
think are important and some
of them come from talking
to Susan Bernstein afterwards,
seven, eight years afterwards.
One of the questions I asked her is,
what would you have done differently
when you came into that meeting and said,
I noticed these two guys were at
one another's throats, is there,
is there a different way
you would have handled that?
And she said a couple of things that
I think are really helpful in thinking
about how to do this,
how to,
how to translate this capacity.
She said, first of all,
these are real data guys. You
know their Mbas, they got,
they think live, breathe, eat numbers.
She said,
first of all,
I would have gone in and the first thing
I would have done would be to address
what they were interested and show
them, you know, I saw the numbers.
This is how I perceive them.
Rather than saying,
this is the main thing I noticed.
She said,
because right away what I learned with
them is they were going to see that as to
some degree off topic.
So getting out of the way,
addressing what I understood was important
to them would have been helpful to me.
She said.
Secondly,
I should have been more data like in my
presentation of what I noticed rather
than just saying and I noticed this
and then trying to give the details,
you know, so and so's um, uh, ad men, uh,
seem to sit in a place that
the other admin was, you know,
all these kind of little details that
she was giving to justify or explain what
she noticed.
She said,
I wish I had presented that more as
data going in and saying something like,
here's what I noticed about the numbers.
Here's what I think is
important about that. I,
I will say that in order for this to
happen and that to happen and that to
happen,
we need to have a real strong commitment
from the two principals because here's
one way that could fall apart.
Here's another way that could fall apart.
So that I was really explaining to them
why I thought it was important for them
for their bottom line,
but what they were concerned
about that these two principles,
we're on the same page she said.
And then if I had sad and I have concerns
about how long term their commitment
to one another is,
and I can share with you the reasons
for those concerns offline. She said,
because in a way there these guys were a
little bit uncomfortable with that kind
of material,
you know,
so I can explain that to you
when we're offline if you'd like,
but I have concerns and here I think are
some of the potential consequences for
us for our division.
If there are problems down the line.
Here are a couple of scenarios.
She said I could have even had a slide
or two about what these scenarios were.
She said,
in other words,
if I had really translated that into
a style of presentation that they were
comfortable with rather than presenting
it as very contextual and almost as they
would see it subjective,
I think I would have had
a better shot she said.
But the other thing I learned is the,
the big mistake I made was to
back off and to immediately think,
oh boy, I blew it. Um, and, and to,
to take that to heart and
pull away from it, she said,
because what she said,
I should have gone in there really
prepared to not argue the case,
but present the case for why this was
important and represent that she said,
because that's really the vision part.
She said,
my vision here is we needed
to address this issue.
We needed to recognize this issue.
We needed to be prepared for the kinds
of things that could go wrong because of
this issue. Uh, that was my
vision. That's what I saw.
She said,
Anne,
I needed to explain it in terms that
they understood and I needed to,
to be prepared to defend myself
instead of just quickly backing off.
So I think that's,
that's sort of the, the,
the takeaway here is be prepared to,
I don't want to use the word defend it,
but be prepared to back it
up and stand your ground.
But know that in presenting
what you have to present,
if you're presenting
to a very bottom line,
get to the point,
um,
focused notice boss or someone you,
you want to be able to articulate that
in a way that they are comfortable with
and where they're not being asked to
imagine a situation that they're not very
good at noticing or judging because
that's going to them. Make them feel like,
how did I miss that? Is, is
something wrong with me? Clearly not.
She's one of these touchy feely women.
It was all concerned about what people's
relationships are with one another.
That's not really what we're here for.
We're business consultants.
So she said she could have
really handled that differently.
Um,
and understood that bringing both
perspectives together could be really
valuable.
There's one other thing I want to say
because I've gotten very aware of this
kind of presentation
since the book came out.
And since I've worked with some women,
I've worked down in San Diego for awhile
with women in a biotech firm who are
having real problems presenting what
some of their research points are because
they were getting a critiqued
as being all over the map.
So we were really trying to almost
reverse engineer and figure out what,
what do you need in this
presentation about this data?
What is going to set these guys at ease?
And in watching, because I would, um,
we did some role playing,
but in watching some of the presentations,
here's one thing I saw over and over.
Women would often start with a kind of
backstory to let their listeners know how
they came up with what they came
up with. Said, well, you know,
I am going to tell you how I came to
this research and I'll tell you this
research point in a moment.
But let me tell you how I got there.
Let me tell you the process by
which I got there. Uh, you know,
I was having a conversation with so
and so. You've lost them already.
If you've got a really
tightly focused focus noticer,
a laser light guy,
his mind almost clicks off when you
start to tell him what the backstory is.
Much more powerful because
we've gone through this,
we've gone through this
process and watched it work
much more powerful is to be
able to present it in a very focused
data like way and then say if you're
interested at some point
in how I got to this,
be glad to share it with you
but not do it as the opener.
Because often women use personal stories
to establish relationship as a way of
sharing and preparing
to share information.
And often not always, there are men
who are very different than this,
but often with men in
real business situations,
that's not cultural for them and it's
not something they're comfortable with so
it can numb.
It can certainly be surmounted.
And this was one of my goals in
developing and looking at, you know,
what is a female vision?
How can that be incorporated?
Part of it is how do we interpret it?
So, great question. Does that help?
Thank [inaudible] about
describing things,
um,
to an audience that is more laser like
in their focus and starting with data and
then offering to tell a personal story
if it would be helpful at the end.
Correct. Um, I feel like striking that
balance is really hard. I know that,
that when I,
you know,
in the past have started with telling
a personal story or making a personal
connection,
um,
that it has been met at times with
skepticism and then, you know,
you lose your audience and
then you can't get it back.
And I feel like I've over corrected now.
Now I feel like I,
I don't talk about myself as often.
I don't make those personal connections.
I don't share those stories because
I've over corrected, um, after it had,
you know, having been met with this
skepticism. Yeah. And I do feel like,
especially at Google,
it's helpful to tell those
personal stories and make
those personal connections
even with people with a laser like
focus. Yeah. And so, you know,
getting it right here I think has been
a challenge because, uh, you know,
I understand what you're talking about,
but I feel like this environment
may be a little unique. Yeah. Um,
at least on the legal team, I
think we're, we're where I work.
Uh Huh. You know, I love that because, um,
I have watched women do this and the,
the biotech team that I was working
with for awhile, that began to happen.
They began to, okay, we're going to do
this, we're going to do the data thing.
And suddenly they had lost
their personality. And you know,
women are often very ripe
to be criticized. And it
was like, well, you know,
she's a robot. Uh, she doesn't seem
to have any warmth or personality.
This is what happened to Susan Bernstein,
the woman up in the bay area when, uh,
up in the East Bay when
she said, um, you know,
I lost who I was.
I lost what part of what my
authentic value was. And she said,
I began to,
I remember years ago,
I bought a fantastic quote from a woman
that just to me epitomized what happens
when you lose your authenticity at work.
She said sometimes I feel as if my body
is only vehicle to carry my head to the
computer and to me that sort of
encapsulate everything we want to avoid as
people and I think that comes when
you suppress what's good in yourself.
So what you're doing,
what your,
your you're noticing,
excuse me,
you're noticing that you overcorrected
is part of a process I believe of coming
to a very strong and authentic way
of being in the world and presenting
yourself.
On one hand you,
you had the confidence and the humility
to notice that the way you were
presenting wasn't necessarily
landing and the way you wanted.
So you made corrections but then you're
open to also noticing that you corrected
too far and you're searching
to find that balance point.
But you can't search to find that balance
point unless you are aware of what
both feel like.
And it sounds as if you are.
So I would say that this is really part
of this process to getting toward a very
strong and our authentic way of
presenting what your vision is.
And that one of the things I hope is that
being able to recognize and articulate
some of these differences,
putting it in the frame of laser and
radar notice and recognize and where your
own capabilities and comfort level lies,
that that in itself can be helpful and
identifying what the issue is and then in
coming to understand how to take action.
Okay,
let me go to the one other quick insight
from the book that I'd like to share
and uh, and then we'll,
we'll, we'll do more of this.
And in terms of focusing
on what it means to you
talk about vision, this is
what you notice. Then the
next step is what you value.
So one thing we were really wanted
to learn was, are there similar,
what are the similarities and differences
in what men and women really value
about their work,
about their experience in the
organizations they're part of?
Where's that overlap?
How does that happen? Um,
so we ran out a big,
because getting, you know,
when you ask a question about what
you value, it can be pretty abstract.
So what we did was we ran out of big
study looking at similarities and
differences in how men and women perceive,
define and pursue satisfaction at work.
And what we found that was a big study.
We used Harris Interactive to
deliver it to a huge sample of,
of people at a variety of levels,
director and above in organizations.
And what we found is that there were
some strong similarities between what men
and women valued. Uh, they
wanted to be recognized,
they wanted to feel authentic at work.
They want recognized for
the real achievements. They,
they took great satisfaction in being
a part of a team or leading a team and
they took great satisfaction in achieving
goals and being able to check those
off.
But we found two areas of significant
difference in terms of value.
And I think this has a real impact in
terms of how you think about your vision
and positioning yourself
in the organization.
The two areas that were different
were, first of all, women tended to
define their success based on their own
terms that they had set for themselves.
Whereas the men in the study really
defined success almost exclusively in
competitive terms. I came
out ahead of him, uh,
and therefore I'm satisfied.
So it was very competitive in terms
of how they perceived success,
whereas women were more likely to
have their own benchmarks for success.
And the other thing was that women were
more focused upon and tended to judge as
satisfying the everyday
experience of work that they had.
Um,
whereas the man that we studied were more
likely to perceived satisfaction based
on position and monetary reward
position and monetary reward.
We're important for women not saying that,
but they were important to women in
the context of also having a satisfying
experience of every day.
And that experience was often defined by,
um,
the ability to develop high quality
relationships and maintain them over time
and by the capacity to some extent,
uh, control their own pace, uh,
at work. And, um,
and these differentials I
think really do matter. Uh,
and when we think about it,
one of the things that we see is that
organizations given this often define
motivation or assume motivation
based on primarily male criteria.
The idea is competitive ranking
will be a spur to performance,
maybe, maybe not. It's
kind of a diversity issue.
Competitive ranking isn't going to be
a spur to performance for everyone.
Um, and, and yet we see, I mean,
we even see organizations even now
adopting these competitive curves,
uh,
which can be very problematic.
And in this strikes me as
not much of an issue here,
which makes my heart sing. I will say, uh,
it seems that there's real attention
here to what the quality of people's
experience is, at least from
the, from the optics. Uh,
and that that is really important for
creating organizations that really
motivate women to develop their best.
That what is the everyday experience.
Um,
one thing we found when we interviewed
women who had left high positions that
were very monetarily, um, what we found,
they tended to say was to do
something else. They'd say,
I decided it just wasn't worth it.
Meaning while the money and
the position were great,
those weren't as profoundly intrinsic to
what my values were because my everyday
experience was not fulfilling because I
didn't feel like I had any control over
my pace, for example. Um,
I didn't feel that I could value that.
So I think it's really
important in organizations,
and this is something for,
uh,
for everybody who's out there to think
about to some extent, you know, we're,
we're looking at diversity
as an issue so often,
but motivation is a
diversity issue as well.
People are motivated by different
things and it's really helpful for us as
individuals to recognize what really
motivates us and to share that information
because that's helpful
to the organization.
It's helpful to our bosses what really
gets us engaged and it's not going to be
the same for everyone. So I think
that's an important point. Any, uh,
any question or observation on this?
So in my old job in public accounting,
I felt like every time there is a happy
hour or like an employee appreciation
thing, it was always like, here's a bunch
of food and alcohol. And it was like,
that was kind of like what they thought,
like how they felt like they were like
paying people back or thinking them.
And I like tried multiple times kind of
to talk to HR and say like I would much
more appreciate like a massage or a
spa day or something like where I could
relax that was so it wouldn't make me
feel appreciated as opposed to like hear
like you just worked like 80 hour weeks.
So like drink all the alcohol you
aren't like, that's like get your,
get your money back that way. You
know? So I think it was, and I,
it was never something that they really
valued or like really tried to change or
like let's do a wine tasting class.
Like even if you want to do alcohol,
like let's look like,
let's do something a little bit different
than like greasy food and a happy hour.
So I was just like an observation,
just like for that,
like just not listening really.
Or like really trying to see like what
would motivate people or make them feel
appreciated. And it sounds like there's
a reason you're not there anymore.
Yes. And that it's a kind of mismatch
of values and I think more and more,
I mean this is one of
the gifts that women,
and also I think a younger generation
which is well represented here of workers
upbringing in being more in touch
with what really motivates them.
A greater understanding of that
and a willingness to what you do,
what you did, which was to try to
tell them, you may find, you know,
there are people here who find this
highly motivating and rewarding than there
are people like me who don't
find it that motivating.
Why not look more broadly too to think
about what what could engage people and
what I see with organizations is more
focus on how do we engage diverse
employees but often not thinking of
that in terms of motivation and reward.
And I believe that is something that's
going to be changing over the next 10
years. That there's going to be
a much more recognition that,
I mean in the old days,
you know, they, they,
they give recognition to a male executive
would be a mink stole for his wife.
You know, how generic
can you get? So we're,
we're moving to something that's
kind of the madman era. Um,
we're moving to something that is much
more customized and we're really part of
that. So, um,
three things going,
looking at what this can mean for those
of you who are here and out there in
terms of how you think about
your own leadership capacity,
we've talked a bit about how
important it is to articulate,
um,
what you see the power of what you see,
the value of what you notice in a way
that those who have a different spectrum
of notice can understand
the, the, if you will,
responsibility to think about how you're
going to translate that in order to
really stand behind it strongly.
But there's another aspect of the notice,
a duality that I think is important to
understand and it has to do with not
expecting those who have a very focused
notice to notice certain things about.
You had a great example of
it right here in the valley,
uh,
with a young woman engineer.
I said electronic arts or something.
I'm not remembering because it was
a big workshop. Anyway, she, Ellen,
Isaac's,
I do remember a name and I remember a
face and we were talking about this notice
saying business and what different
people notice. And she said, you know,
I had the best example of that.
This really helps me understand something.
She said,
I've always thought of myself as a real
goto person in the organization. Uh,
people contact me about things that
might not even relate directly to my job.
I get lots of calls, lots of
emails, people in and out of
my office. She said, Anne,
and a couple of weeks ago,
we went offsite on a, um,
a retreat where we had our
performance review done. She said,
and my performance, my boss was there.
My performance review came back.
We had a talk about it, she
said, and basically what he
said was, she's terrific.
She does very high quality
work, but she does. Um,
she does, she's not broadly enough
connected in the organization.
She seems to spend a lot of
time in her office. She thought,
what the very thing I think I'm best at,
he doesn't notice how
can that be possible?
And she said she spent some time
after that really feeling bad,
wondering if she should work for the
guy who she really liked working for.
Um, and just kind of taking
it to heart. She said,
I felt like I'd been
punched in the stomach to be
criticized on the thing I felt
I was best about. She said, but
listening to this, she said,
what I realize is I was expecting him to
notice something that he may not just,
is kind of not in his
radar span for noticing.
How would he know how
broadly connected I am?
I never told him. He doesn't monitor my
emails, see who comes into my office.
Um, he doesn't monitor my phone
calls. I had never told him. She said,
so what I realized I had to do was come
up with a way to share this information
with him explicitly.
So she began a kind of um,
program for herself where she,
um,
every two weeks she sent
him an email saying,
talk to so and so connected these two
people, et Cetera, et cetera. She said,
I felt so nervous about doing that.
I felt so frightened about doing that.
I thought he was going to say,
why is she wasting my time with this?
Why is she blowing her own horn?
All of a sudden to me, she
said, his response was,
this is information I need to know because
what you're doing is strengthening me
your bit because you work for me.
You are building my connections and
I need to know that information.
So she had a real recognition of,
of the power of handling that well and
getting past this sort of shyness about
articulating what she
was doing to her boss,
but really also recognizing I went in
there expecting he would just notice
things that I might notice even though
I had plenty of information to let me
know that that's not how he saw
things. He wasn't always, I wonder,
I wonder what Alan's doing.
I wonder if Ellen knows this person
said it wasn't on his radar screen.
It's not really how he thinks. So, um,
that's the other side of the notice.
So you thinking about your vision and
I think it's really important for us to
articulate and to have in mind really an
idea for describing what our vision is.
Whatever we are in a job,
what is my vision for what I could be
doing in this job and how does that fit
with the larger vision I have of what
could be helpful for this organization.
The more you can articulate that and
have it almost in your back pocket, um,
the more powerful it will be.
But also what's great about doing that
is you can use the vision that you have
to begin to build allies in a very
strategic way in organizations today.
There's so much emphasis on getting a
mentor and getting a sponsor and all that.
And I thought Cheryl Sandberg did a
great job of addressing why that can
sometimes be problematic.
Certainly I've worked in organizations
where the women who are in very senior
positions are besieged with
requests to be mentors and sponsors,
um, in often a way that
somewhat in organic. Uh,
and I think that the emphasis on it,
although it's very,
very helpful and important.
And I've seen organizations where
women's opportunities are transformed by
mentoring and sponsor ship programs,
but allies,
sponsors and mentors or one kind
of ally and allies can be peers.
They can be people who report to us.
They're people who are engaged in
helping you achieve what you want and who
recognize that in doing that they
can strengthen themselves as well.
That's what an ally is.
So it's not necessarily a level.
And I believe that women can really
strengthen themselves by using the vision
that they articulate to enlist allies.
Women are great at building
relationships in general,
but they're not always as great
at leveraging relationships
as making sure those
relationships help them achieve what
they're trying to achieve and helping the
people who are allied with them also
achieve what their objectives are.
Often we can be shy about saying,
this is what I'm trying to do,
this is how you can help me and this is
how you can benefit from that and oh by
the way, what can I do for
you? One thing I've noticed,
and I've had this discussion often with
people in HR and I had this discussion
with hedge with head hunters as well,
is women will come into
a position and think,
I need to get really good at this.
I'm going to keep my head down for the
next six months and I'm going to master
this job and then I can look up and
start to bring people in around me.
Whereas often you'll find a
successful male, we'll go into a job.
And the his first question is
who do I need to reach out to?
Who can help me make this a success?
So right away he's engaging people who
is going to help me be successful at
this.
And the result is that he has more support
and more visibility for what he does.
That keeping your head down and trying
to become an expert can cost you in terms
of visibility and support.
So it's something that
I always have urged and,
and the reasons and the techniques
around it change over time.
But for women,
it's really important to think once you
have articulated what you're trying to
do, who can help me build this?
How can I bring people in?
How can I leverage their skills?
I did a program at a huge global
financial institution in DC,
DC based a couple of months ago.
Uh, it was a big women's program.
There were hundreds of women there and
they were in a place of some degree of
discouragement.
And what I learned was
that the organization had
recently done a survey on who
people preferred as bosses and men and
women both perceived that having a male
boss was more desirable.
And I was fascinated by this.
So once we'd done our program I said,
can I, can I do some backgrounding here?
Can I learn a little more about why this
was what it is in your culture that was
responsible for that? What I learned
were two things. First of all,
in that environment where there were
very few women who are bosses, women,
we're often perceived of as tougher
bosses because they were so invested in
doing things kind of perfectly themselves
that they seem to have less tolerant.
But the other thing which relates to
this is that men were perceived to have
better connections in the
organization as a whole.
And people wanted to be on a team
where where their boss had a lot of
connections because they understood and
recognized that that was going to be
good for them down the line.
So to the extent that you're not
building alliances and connections,
that's going to have an impact upon
also how your team perceives you.
Um, so I think it's something
really important. And again,
building relationships is not always
the same thing as leveraging them.
Remember we talked about
citizen Bernstein saying,
I wish I had been able to stand up for
what I saw and standing up I think is
something we need to think about.
I have been asked for 25 years what
women need to do to build a stronger,
more effective leadership presence.
Do Women need to have a farmer handshake?
Is that how we walk what we're wearing?
Should you carry a person to a meeting?
Are you making yourself look weaker if
you're carrying a purse or encumbered and
other ways, it's always
cosmetic, what the questions are.
But having spent 25 years working
with some of the best women leaders,
best leaders around the world,
I've come to the conclusion that what
really builds leadership presence is the
capacity to be present,
to be present in the moment
for the person in front of you,
for the task in front of you,
for the actual situation that you're in.
And there is a reason that the word
presence and present are essentially the
same it that those are connected.
And what's rather daunting
about this is that in a 24,
seven environment that we're part of
where technology is a part of how we're
interacting all the time.
It can be difficult to build,
to be responsive,
to do your job,
but in the course of doing that,
also build the kind of leadership
presence that gives you real strengths and
makes you perceived of as a leader.
Because the environment we're
part of is inherently distracting.
Years ago before I got into this at all.
Um,
I said I had done a lot of speech
writing for executives and it was so
fascinating because when
I go to conferences and
working with the executives,
you could always tell
that the executive was,
because he never saw
a woman in those days.
He was unencumbered and he didn't
have anything he was worried about.
Everybody else was worried
about what was going on,
but he didn't need to worry about where
am I notes or what's happening or where
is this or what's the right
door or, oh, it's raining.
How am I going to get to the door?
Or carrying a raincoat. Fine.
Things were taken care of
and he could be present.
Sometimes he wasn't because sometimes it
was the Kinda guy who couldn't look at
anybody, look anybody in the
eye. But he had that capacity.
And what's fascinating is to look at the
extent to which the environment we're
part of can undermine our
capacity to be present,
but even as it does so it,
it weakens our ability to
really manifest presence. Uh,
and I do think that it can be harder
for women partly because of our radar,
that capacity to be noticing what people,
how things are landing on somebody or
how engaged someone is noticing what's
going on in the room.
That radar light capacity,
while it has real strength also has the
potential to undermine our ability to be
fully present.
So what I've seen are a
number of practices I share
three today that really are
helpful in being able to maintain
the capacity to be fully present,
which I believe is absolutely essential
for sending a message about your
potential as a leader.
People get that.
We get it at a level that's
here rather than here.
We understand when someone is
present or when they're not. Um,
and we understand that across cultures.
That's,
that's something else I think
that's really important.
People can recognize you.
We have all these training programs.
You know,
if you're in a meeting and someone's
a Muslim don't show you yet, you know,
the bottom of your shoe and all
these kinds of techniques we get at
communicating across culture.
But people understand and recognize
if your present across culture.
That's something that really translates.
So I believe it is a tremendous advantage
to all of us to think about what do we
need to do to be as present as we can.
What I've seen work is number one,
be your own HR department.
And by that I mean think
through what policies, uh,
what practices do you need to incorporate
into how you do things that protect
your ability to be thoughtful
and effective rather than
constantly responding
what works for you.
We're all different in this way and
that's why I say be your own HR department
because this isn't something that
can be handed down as policy.
If we're really starting from the point
of what is going to help me be present
and be effective and be thoughtful,
what do I need to do to
enable that to happen?
How do I need to use my time
and my technology and my
interactions in a way that
will really support that?
So some real mindfulness and
intention around doing that.
When we're going into a new project,
negotiate our time,
needs in advance as much as we can.
It's not an ideal world,
but negotiate that in time and,
and sell,
maybe sell up.
I did some work at Microsoft and this
woman that was a general manager there
talk, when I was talking about
this, she said, you know,
what I did is I realized that the constant
stream of text was really undermining
me.
And I talked to my boss and said,
I'm going to do an experiment where I
turn this off for a certain number of
hours a day and I will not be able
to necessarily respond. She said,
and I was able to kind of sell
that to him and then I was able to,
speaking of data document how
it improved my effectiveness.
So that became part of my policy
for how I managed my time.
So I think that's setting policies is,
is really important.
The second thing, and I think this
is particularly important for women,
uh,
in my experience is to recognize
and address compulsive or addicting
multitasking.
Women often take pride in
their capacity to multitask.
Um, and the world we live
in, we all multitask.
I'm not advocating,
I'm sometimes I've talked,
I've given this talk and I get into
the elevator and some woman's in the
elevator on her cell phone. She says,
Oh, I, I'm sorry, I'm sorry. You know,
she's almost defending me
because she feels like, oh,
she thinks I'm multitasking.
We live in a world that requires
a certain degree of multitasking,
but it is important to recognize
that while it is efficient,
there is always a cost.
Because if you are doing
two things at once,
you by definition cannot be
present for both of them.
Your attention is divided,
your attention is fractured,
you're more likely to make mistakes and
it is inherently more stressful because
stress is produced when
our attention is divided,
not when we're working hard. That's what
is stressful. I've got to do this, oh,
hung under the what time
is a plane going to come?
And then I've got to get there
and maybe I should recalculate.
That's where stress lives.
Stress lives in divided attention
and the more present one can be,
and again,
I feel that I've watched this and
witnessed this by being exposed to highly
effective senior executives.
They have the resources that help
them to be present because they're not
worrying about the details.
Most of us don't have that luxury.
We have to worry,
we have to sweat the details,
but the more we can do that in a way
where we're mindful of where is this
addictive,
whereas this habitual,
how important is it that I
respond to this right now?
And the more we can
protect our effectiveness,
the more leadership presence we will
be able to a fact and the more we'll be
able to represent and gain
respect for an understanding of,
of what our vision is.
And the final thing is,
as Buddhists recognize,
presence is a practice.
Being present is a practice and that's
what meditation and meditational pursuits
are about.
Their way of practicing being present and
it's presence is not something you can
just tell yourself, I'm going to be
present. I've decided starting now,
I'm going to be fully present.
It doesn't work that way.
It's something that you incorporate into
being and you do that through practice
that you're not hung.
The Vietnamese monk has a wonderful
practice that he uses when he works with
people in offices.
He says,
every time that phone rings,
every time you hear that bell,
use it like monks in a monastery.
Use a month a monastery bell.
Take one second to call yourself
to attention and depressants.
Take a breath.
When you hear it.
Let your practice be to remind you.
When you hear a bell, when you hear
the text, Peng, whatever it is,
I'm here now, I'm present.
I'm in the moment, I am here.
And if you can do that,
you can begin to develop that muscle
that enables you to be present.
And by the way,
you'll be a lot more effective when you
pick up the phone rather than, yeah,
you'll be,
can I help you?
That's much more present.
So thinking of it in terms of presence,
and I think this is something
that's very powerful. I said, um,
the presence translates across culture.
It even translates against across species,
which is a big deal.
If anybody watched, say czar the
dog whisperer, that's all he does.
You know the other,
the,
the dog owners walk into their
house and the dog goes nuts.
Say's our Walk Sen dog is
total attention and all it is,
is he as fully present and aware.
So if that can translate across species,
anybody who's tried to ride a horse
knows how that effective is if you're
thinking about 10
different things at once.
So being able to bring that practice
into what you do is going to help you
represent your vision with real
power and authority and influence.
And Oh,
by the way,
you'll be much less stressed
and distracted in the process.
So you mentioned Sheryl Sandberg.
I'm curious what are,
you mentioned Bud Sheryl Sandberg's book
and was actually curious your thoughts
in terms of the lien in kind of
decree for women. Well, first of all,
I think Sheryl's book was one of the
great contributions of the last 10 years.
It,
what I see is it has gotten
companies thinking much more,
um,
at a much higher level about what they
need to do to engage women and it's made
it acceptable.
I did a program at a big energy company
that was very traditional and top down
and they had a male panel,
which I was moderating and all four men
on the panel showed up carrying her book
to kind of show how on board they were.
So it's kind of given man,
I think because of her status permission
to be interested in this issue,
which is extremely important and many,
many of the points she made I
thought were really very important.
We do it.
It doesn't just happen leadership,
it involves that stepping up and
making that commitment and saying,
I really want this to work.
This may not be the place I may
need to go to another place,
but I really want to invest in my career.
And I think that's what she was saying.
And I so dislike the
criticism that you know,
whoa easy for her to say she's
got all these resources. That's,
that's not the point.
The point is she was encouraging and
saying you can have a richer, fuller,
more meaningful life if you
invest yourself in your career.
On the other hand,
this
propensity of women to look at the actual
quality of their day is something that
is pretty deeply ingrained.
I don't think it has to be an either or.
On one hand it doesn't have
to be so non strategic lie.
I'm not enjoying this particular job.
I've had five bad days in a row. I think
I'm going to quit. That's, you know,
that is not leaning and that is not
stepping up a, that's getting discouraged.
What we find is that over time,
if day after day after day,
the experience of work is
profoundly unsatisfying,
women are more likely to say that salary,
that position was not worth it because
I am just not enjoying my life.
I believe this is one of the great
gifts that women have to bring to the
workplace because I've read a lot of
research about the millennial generation
and what they value and it's much
more similar to what women value.
It's that interest in what
is the quality of my life.
I'm moving into organizations.
I know I'm going to be working 60 hours
a week. If I'm going to get anywhere.
I know how much my job is
going to be all consuming.
I need to be able to enjoy it.
I need to be able to feel as if
my contribution is really valued.
I want to feel a part of what I'm doing.
And that's what we hear from the men and
women of that millennial generation who
come into, you know, people say, oh,
they're so entitled. Well first of all,
their parents told them good job when
they, you know, picked up a quarter, uh,
they've been told over and over, you're
terrific. You can do anything. Um,
and so of course they have that attitude
and I happened to believe that attitude
can be very adaptive in today's
workplace because we're so much of his ex
expected of us. But I, one
of the things I often say,
and I say to executives who are saying,
you know,
our women seem to feel like
work should be enjoyable.
I say be grateful because you have
an opportunity to think through the
experience of work at this place and
prepare yourself for that next generation,
next generation whose attitude,
excuse me,
whose attitude is much more likely
to be similar to that of women.
So this is again,
I believe what happened like with those
leadership competencies is women are to
a degree on the cutting edge
of how organizations will
need to adapt to be able
to really engage their
talent at the highest level.
And that it is helpful.
It behooves to use an old fashion word
organizations to be able to listen to
that. And it's helpful for us in
terms of really making that case.
I did not see in Sheryl's book
this big divide between um,
stepping up and valuing the
quality of your everyday.
Obviously every day isn't going to be a
picnic and there are days that are going
to be extremely difficult.
Uh,
it's really over time when you begin
to perceive a misfit or mismatch like
woman,
Susan Bernstein debt as a
result of feeling I cannot
be authentic and this job.
Um, but it's also possible, I mean,
again, that woman Ellen, Isaac's that,
um,
I met out here in the valley who felt
so discouraged because she felt like her
boss didn't see what she really had,
what her best qualities were
there ways we can address that.
If we have an awareness of it,
there are ways we can make that better.
And um,
she reported that I made an enormous
difference to her that she felt like her
boss really saw,
really noticed her and noticed what was
best about her and that was profoundly
rewarding to her and gave her much more
feeling of freedom and much more feeling
like she really fit
with this organization.
So I think the message is hopeful.
I felt Cheryl's message was very helpful
and very hands on in terms of specific
advice. And uh, you know, as I said,
I've been doing this 25 years and one of
the advantages of that is being able to
take a big picture,
long term view.
And I believe this is the best time I
have ever seen in 25 years for women to be
able to make an impact.
And help their organizations
really use their best talents.
Uh,
it takes being able to articulate and
understand the power of what those best
talents are. But, uh,
but I think we're in a time where
organizations are certainly,
in my view, more ready to hear
that than they have been, um,
in decades.
So I wish you luck and I thank you.